Hello and welcome, everyone.
Thanks for joining.
It's November 30th 20, 21
and we're in ActInfLab LiveStream number 33.2
on "Thinking like a state:
embodied intelligence in the deep history of our collective minds."
This is the second discussion we've had on this paper.
And if you're watching Long Live definitely ask us questions
because it'll help us have a fun feedback and discussion.
Welcome to Active Inference Lab.
We are a participatory online lab
that is communicating, learning and practicing applied active inference.
You can find us at the links here on this slide.
This is a recorded and an archived live stream,
so please provide us with feedback so that we can improve our work.
All backgrounds and perspectives are welcome
and we'll be following good video etiquette for lectures
it's a new slide.
The short link is gone.
It's been deprecated thanks to the work of many awesome
active lab participants and especially Jessica B,
we have moved over our live stream past
an upcoming database to a coder site.
So you can go to this Coda site or maybe somebody can post a link.
And this is an interactive way for you to look at the date video,
the title, the number,
the guests that were on the stream, the keywords, all the links.
This is linked up with our knowledge management as well as our people
management. CRM, as they call it.
So this is an awesome tool that we're using with Kota
and hopefully it improves the find ability and the index ability
so that if you're looking for some keyword,
you can find all the live streams where we discuss that keyword.
Or if you have somebody who you like to listen to,
then you can find them in the guests or in the participant section.
And you can hear what they had to say
about a certain topic at a certain time.
Today in
Active Stream 33.2, we're going to be having our dot to jump off
slash speculate onwards and upwards.
Discussion on the paper by Avel Guénin–Carlut, "Thinking like a state:
embodied intelligence in the deep history of our collective minds."
So we'll just have fun.
We have some topics from last time that we put on a slide for 33.2
that we can talk a little bit through as always, things come up
and it'd be great to have anyone's questions in the live chat, otherwise
we're just going to be chilling and talking about this cool paper.
So we will start with introductions and then just take it from there.
I'm Daniel.
I'm a researcher in California,
and I'll save my specific excitements or what I'd like to or remembered
about the paper for our kind of intro round and I'll pass to the.
I am Denham Calgary.
And I'm kind of interested, like said, in seeing
what happens when like our migration from Google to Coda
and we and we pick up and move off of some of these representations
or some of these ideas what that looks like.
And I'll pass it over to Steven.
Hello, I'm Steven.
I'm based in Toronto
and and yeah, I'm interested about the generative business.
I think this paper starts to create and I've had some good conversations
with Dean actually, and we've been chewing over
how much this maybe opens new doors
maybe is a step too far at this stage.
And the where other doors we might have that
we can step into.
So it's
I think it's an interesting set of mirrors and the alleyways to go into.
So I'm curious what those doors are.
Which ones have ramps, which ones are downhill
which ones are a spiral staircase?
Like what places would one go from this paper?
And I'm sure we can start even writing on our 33.2 slide, like,
what are those doors?
Are they ajar?
Are they locked?
So, Daniel, one of the things in
I don't know if this is sense making or just messing with something,
but if a city was made up, oftentimes
like what we see in some of the empty ashes work
and then there were Markoff blankets all over the place,
what might that look like relative to sort of the
the city that I live in
or the city that you live in or the city that Steven lives in?
And are there ways that we can air the similarities?
And are there real differences between what
that sort of mixture world and mark of blankets
would represent as versus their actual representations of actual cities?
That's one of my questions.
So let me kind of unpack that.
You're talking about the M.C.
Ascher art with the stairs going in different apparent directions
and asking
whether those portals would reflect intelligently designed
transporters
or what does that physical or cyber physical city look like?
Yeah.
And many of these large rooms, you've had one image on the slide
that has the ants walking around the I forget what that symbol is.
Yeah. Mobius strip with an answer to.
The Mobius Strip.
So that would be an example of a real representation
that we could generate.
But is that a city? That's my question.
OK, Stephen, and welcome, Dave.
Yeah. Is that as it is?
I mean, it also takes me thinking about cyclotrons or just simple
transect walks, which is what you can do in a participatory
engagement with a town or something where literally you transact,
you walk through a cross section of a town
that you're not encountering it's the ways of structuring participation.
But it's it's an interesting question, right?
So basically start to move through
and we go through a path and start to see what's on that route.
And it's the same thing.
That's a question that goes back to you
as to why the doorways, it's like they're gone.
So to find my doorways and start squeezing through the doorway
or when do I need to again step back
and find the unifying principles
and where do I need to go back to accuracy and complexity?
And when do I go in to try and force through the doorway, you know, and
active influences allow me to
step back and hold more rather than try and not worried
about fitting through the doorway.
However,
as we realize we're talking here, like at some point
you need to put stuff into the communications
encoder and Google Docs, you know, so in some ways
you're going to categorize for practice practical purposes, right?
But it's not the same as walking on the Mobius Strip.
So there's an interesting challenge as practitioners that we face Hmm.
OK. Welcome back, Dave. I hope it's working.
Just everyone remember to, you know, mute
if you're not talking and turn off all your messaging applications.
The idea of the transact, that reminds me a lot of ecology
where we know that there's spatial and temporal variation
but a common approach is to take a transect, like either going up
an elevation gradient or going within the same elevation gradient.
So those are kind of like the two directions that we always talk about
going on, the rotational component that climbs straight up the hill
to see how elevation changes biodiversity or to go at the same altitude
maybe on a north to south to ask how does latitude influence
biodiversity at a given elevation that's like that ISO contour.
So then the transect is a sampling approach
that in the context of a generative model gives us a picture of
the map
of the territory so yeah. Steven.
Yeah, that's good.
I think it's probably been ported over when whoever did
that is probably more used in participatory development and
community development than participatory theater.
And so it's like support development might touch on it,
but a lot of times space of work doesn't really let up.
When you go there. They just talk about scenes and situations.
But I I think the transit is a nice way to sort of walk through
and get a cross section in that kind of semi scientific way.
But I actually then was much more interested in going through social
topography, just allowing people to get the whole landscape out there,
which in some ways
once we get
into the kind of agent based work,
which I didn't know about that, but you know,
then the argument would be, well,
the transit is already adding all this complication.
You've got people who can take in a cross section of the town
as opposed to having something nice and clean, adding some why,
why go even further.
But in my experience as well, it's OK
if you regime if attention is being organized around a certain type of
objective inference, right.
So yeah, you don't be doing if you're deducting
because you just get completely swallowed, swallowed up by it
so that that could be interesting.
So cross over that.
Well, it's like one way to take the transect
and perhaps a null transect would be a quote straight line
that would just be unbiased or it's a simple choice.
And then in a city you might want to take that transect
or you might be on rails so you might be taking
the f muni in San Francisco.
And that's like giving you scenes of city life.
And that actually speaks to the difference between Kronos and Kairos.
Kronos is like that straight line that just doesn't care
whether you're putting the meter stick over the city or the mountain
and then Kairos is like that streetcar or the path
that's like you're walking along the path, but it might have curves,
but that's the path that you're on.
So then that's more like Kairos. Then
yeah. So I
don't know whether the author was intending this,
but one of the things that I took away from the paper that I thought was
really potentially an amazing insight from the paper was the fact that
if you go into a city, you can get a sense of a feeling of the city.
So there is a collective feeling
you can I'll take my own personal example.
You can go into the city of Barcelona
and it isn't just where it is situated on a coast
there is a fundamental feeling difference.
As somebody who is now within that geographic territory,
then the one that you
you sense when you're in Madrid or when you're in Lisbon,
they each each have a collective feel about them
and it isn't just that you want it to be different
because the architecture is different
or where it's where it's situated on a hill is different.
There's actual social aspects of that feeling
which make themselves present and which you attune to.
So I don't I would never argue with the fact that as an example of
a collective act of inference that cities couldn't
exhibit those
those types of of not just behavior but sense of of who we are
and what we are, what we are.
But I'm not sure like, again, I'm
not sure if it the scale aspect of this
actually works because as I said in my mind,
I could do the mixture thing all the time.
I can twist things and invert things,
but it's hard to do that with dead things made of concrete.
Not I'm not saying it can't happen,
but I don't see examples of that out there when things scale up and out.
Thanks, Stephen.
Yeah.
And say as you walk in, if you say walking down
these routes in Barcelona, for instance, as you mentioned, that
you know, this the route that we pass along
and that's kind of what's available.
And there's a there's a scale that's friendly to being available.
There's a certain size building that certain
you know, at the end of the day, if you're walking in
or you're going through some ambulatory routes,
there's this things available to you there's this,
but there's also then what's adjacent to that and what's hidden
and what's hidden right next to you.
Maybe there's a homeless person on the site they on the same route.
Are they seeing the same things I'm seeing?
Are they seeing the same affordances? Are they seeing what's you know?
And often that route is where the vantage point is.
So where's where's what's behind that?
All on the right, what's hidden
from the time that we see these buildings.
And I think that that is
that's an interesting question of, you know, this the system
as seen from a perspective and then this what it's really like
in many different contexts.
Thanks Thanksgiving, Dean yeah.
Which which brings me to the rather familiar which to me
standing beside it sticks out at up and all over the place and has
allusions to termite mounds and, and, and, and like it's one of those
attempts, I think to actually mimic the things that we eat here.
And it certainly is building oil and ramping.
I mean, it's if you want an example of where architecture
is actually doing a symbolic
how do you do this?
Rather familiar would be a perfect example of that in terms of what
in terms of what about activity for some of the
some of the shapes we see
kicking out from some of the math
that's happening in the on the in the statistical mechanics.
So that's kind of fascinating to.
You know what you mentioned a few you know, little references
since we're in the fun data there we go viral.
So the Tower of Babel
weather or whatever
it was, it's often at least classically represented as a spiral ascent.
So that's very interesting. That that's it's not like the Tower of Pisa
with just rings.
That's like ISO contours that are separated from each other.
But there's something about the way that it's classically shown
that makes it look more like it's a spiral, which is,
as we've discussed from a technical perspective,
related to the decomposition of that spiral into an uphill irritation
or component and a purely rotational component.
And then the other sort of reference was to William Blake's poem London,
where he says, I wandered through each charted street
near where the chartered Thames does flow and mark in every face
I meet marks of weakness, marks of woe.
So here there's so much about how the streets are chartered,
the flow of people
and the river is chartered,
because it's also part of the niche that's been engineered.
And there's also flow.
Which brings us back to number 32. That was our big lead in was flow.
What is flow and how can different systems have similar mappings
of heat flow, information flow bulk flow, particle flow, liquid flow.
So how does flow matter in a city,
the sewage going out and the resources coming in
and then also it's like even niche modification on our countenance.
It's marked on the faces that Blake is meeting.
Aspects of the city are kind of imprinted on them.
And then that speaks to what Dean was saying
about how there's like a collective feeling that's
partially architectural, but it's like a feedback
that's complex between the people and the time and the place.
So Dean then.
Yeah, and and it's, it's interesting too,
because the article that's part of this,
whether it's a cathedral or, or whatever the artifacts are
they get kicked out.
We can look at that from an ingredient standpoint.
Like we can look at beer as having
water and yeast and barley and, and whatever.
Right.
But but the fact is there's also time required and there's also energy
that has to be applied.
And I think that's the part
the time and the energy piece of city states that are
are the real key to whether or not we can see what
as individuals, we we perceive active inference
as affording versus what on the collective level,
we see act of inference as if I think where it
where it separates is on the specific set the ingredients.
But where the common is is in terms of the energy applied
and the time required.
Thanks, Stephen.
You know, with the idea of the time and energy
and we're to mass scale and stuff,
you know, when you're around the Thames,
when back in the day there was that big, there was a
there was a boat full of
important people and so royalty or the politicians or whatever,
but they were on the Thames and the boat sank
and the people in the water because the water was so putrid
and rank that a lot of them died basically.
And, and that instigated a lot of the cleanup.
So I suppose there's this question of like how close is close?
You know, like you get closer to water
and at some point you put your head in it.
You can't really make anything out of water,
you know, then you've got like certain vantage points which allow you
to understand that you're in a chartered Thames you get so close,
you could be in any body of water and then you move out further.
So there's a there's this there's a scale dependency in terms
of how you can structure.
You relate to the information and then just, you know,
whether you like it, there's a structurally dependent
nature of the scale of the Thames, right?
So I can't walk across the Thames
and it's too small compared to it's Wall Street.
So these are these are some of the questions in terms
of how the information's going to be processed
and how much of that information is adjacent to someone,
how much is if it's hidden, who's those people on that boat
they live next to a smelly tends for a long time, actually,
the people in the House of Commons, you have scented handkerchiefs.
They cut their nose
so that they could overcome the smell of the sewage in the Thames.
And so you know, at some point they got
they got up close and dirty to it and
probably change their perception of what was really going on.
Interesting.
So another thing I had written down
and kind of connecting us to some of the core terms in active affordance
which is the capacity for action,
and those are the opportunities for policy selection.
They're chosen among the different affordances
and in cities, it's very related to ability and access to people
who are walking down the street are able to enter different doors
and they're able to sit down in different places.
And so I think that's a very tangible and important example of embodied
extend it and cultured,
et cetera, cognition, all these and other letters,
because it's something that we all experience.
They're issues that people really care about and
putting them under a
descriptive, I hesitate to say neutral banner of affordances,
financial affordances or physical, or however it may be,
it helps us have a discussion about what the affordances should be.
Should you be able to get into the bus in the back of the bus,
there's trade offs for that.
You know, maybe it's harder to clock the fares,
but then it might be easier to access for some people.
But then now there's this ability for people to evade the fare.
But then how bad is that relative to the busses being late?
If everybody has to go in the front
like all of these kinds of trade offs
act of inference is giving a way to talk about the antic level,
the individual person on the streets of the city and their perception
and cognition and action, which are selected from their affordances,
which are situational, not just like all people can go up a staircase
and then we have a individual level model
and can ask then, OK, collective model
feedback with a niche, and then where adults paper takes
it is like the city and the states as active inference agents
composed of subunit active inference agents, just like
we can have an acronym for model of a body as well as of the cells.
Stephen
Yeah.
I'd be curious what your thoughts are on this, Daniel, in terms of
when when we have the active inference models,
like you mentioned and often, you know, particular low dimensional
ways to get into sort of types of user attention, you know,
maybe it's the model or the nature of people, you know, looking at this
that they're their attentional states, X, Y and Z and the post,
the challenges,
once you go and you start walking through different doors
and you're in a town and you've got this question about what,
how do you model that when when the actual low dimensionality
becomes very hard to to work with
and I suppose that question then is at
what point do you look at what actual people are doing,
which hasn't happened as much in active inference,
and then try and go back
and try and understand, OK, what is what they've done
and how that's inscribed on the leash, reflective of the action
policies and versus how much is it about looking at the sensory room
that might explain the generative model
that we anticipate going on and emulate in that and say
that might relate to I suppose you might have that same question events.
You know, when you try and do an agent based model of a few agents
and as a conceptual
and when you try and understand what answer to in situ,
you know, because obviously that gets kind of complex, right?
Because they're all moving around.
So I don't know that has a correlation
to that question in that field as well.
But I think that relates here to this situated cityscape scale
because it's very granular once you get into that.
And in some ways it's nice to make it become like a mind.
It's nice to make all of that
because suddenly it kind of fits in with the model in
that we kind of use it.
And in some ways it might there may be some validity,
but it may be that the
we have to bring in that mind body environment, dynamic or mess
that opens in questions about what how do we go about that
good question.
So here on this slide, we have the dimensionality of active models.
So we can even just emphasize maps, not territories.
And then what
what does the next step in formalizing this model look like?
So let's think of a specific city situation
and then we can talk about like modeling
that city situation and what would the dimensionality of the Model B,
where does regime of attention come into play?
So what would be like a city situation
common situation, fringe situation,
important situation, like what's a case that we care about in a city,
maybe one that involves complex interactions between,
for example, bureaucracy, which was the main topic of the paper,
and legacy history and affordances of agents.
Think to get there
you'd have to have a lot more of the bottom up aspect of that
being honored as opposed to more of the top down control piece.
I don't know what the final product would look like
because it's act of inference.
I would be inferring and I would think that there would be
there would be
13 million architects and one citizen
which is not how cities are typically designed.
And that's one of the struggles that I have with this in terms of
drawing and drawing a parallel across scales
because there's only one to be.
But I've got however many neurons and I'm kind of dependent on those.
So OK, yes, I see where you're going
and I think we'll we're going to keep the bottom up and top down.
And I think this modeling approach, it's not the only one,
but starting with a scenario and kind of like Bruno, the tours
actor network theory or agent appropriately we can start by identifying
traces and action trajectories in that scenario.
And let's see if in a bottom up way on our first pass,
we can get to like a skeletal active model.
And then the iteration is infinite slash perpetual.
So I don't think it's about just going for one,
getting bottom up input once and then laying the grid work down
and then crusties from there on.
It's an iterated process and this is how we start from the bottom.
We're going to kind of like start from the bottom up of a scenario
that's real, that describes subject verb object
that people will recognize person gets on bus
and then let's think about what active core terms we would want to
apply to different nodes,
recognizing that even the assignment of internal external blanket
states, it's conditional on our model.
It's not like the door is a blanket state outside of us
modeling it a certain way.
And certainly we know external and internal are that way as well.
Stephen And
then we have this, this question of model
and of course this is where the leash and how much the needs can come in
I think one of the things if we take in more modern societies,
I mean certainly more recently
is there's been an increasing role of this top down
or my call literally copy and paste.
I mean,
in Canada they've got something called Shopper's Drug Mart.
They've got these kind of stores now. And having worked in some
agencies, graphic agencies is I can just imagine
like there's like a design for a store, it gets tweaked and it literally
and this couldn't really happen in the past.
It literally gets copied and pasted
and it looks like, you know, looks like, oh, here's another shop,
that's another drug store, but more like a chain, you know, franchise.
McDonald's is a classic case of suppose there's some adaptation,
but it's pretty much like Plunk, Plunk.
And in some ways that's that
that now there's an infant is kind of devoid from active inference.
And that may be part of the problem is the more that it's done that way
and the less that there's a kind of an even in the top down,
there's not really even an inference process going on there anymore.
It's like, what are we going to do I'm just going to copy
and paste using the machine, something that was done elsewhere.
It's not even contextualized from the top down anymore.
It's just we just completely bulldoze whatever we need to make it fit.
Agree that
that's the franchise model, which allows for rapid deployment,
for example, and then on the other side, from the user's perspective,
maybe walking into a franchise is comforting and there is a reduction
of uncertainty about aisle seven is where the cereals are.
Oh, well, I was right there actually.
They're even though I've never been in the city
and so that is definitely a evolutionarily novel context
to have that level of precision of like what you'll find somewhere
you've never been but it allows for an
increasingly globally accessible reduction of surprise.
And maybe we're seeing that the reduction of uncertainty of
what is there
and the quality and how many grams are going to be in that box
and the profit margins of everybody down the line
that system in many cases displaces the, you know, hand
shoveling of granola and every little co-op having its own granola blend
and these are definitely scenarios
that can be models of active inference.
Dave and then. Steve.
Yeah, the cut and paste mentality for corporate decision
making in particular is really destructive.
The single biggest determinant
for where you're going to locate a new business
if you're a corporation, either putting in your own outlets,
doing franchises, is there lots of competition?
There's lots of competition. That's the location I want.
So you've got all these outlets competing with each other.
When you go across town,
there's this whole underserved area where everybody would be happy,
including your employees and your stock owners.
I've seen this in when a Walmart came into my old town the one big draw
that would send people to
the Kmart is Kmart had not changed any of their layouts for decades.
So all the little old ladies who had trouble remembering
where they lived could still find the granola.
So what happens when one Wal-Mart opens up across the street?
Well, they went in, reorganized Kmart and all the little old lady
says, well, if there's no reason to go to Kmart any more,
I might as well save a few cents at Wal-Mart.
And and again, on the first pass,
it's like put it where there's less access to that thing.
But you go, Well, I already know people are shopping here,
and now I can draw people who are shopping and people who are new.
It makes makes dollars, doesn't make sense.
What do they say, Stephen?
Yeah, this this question about how to deal with a niche
is a massive, massive challenge, you know, because the
the bottom up ability to self-organize once that's lost,
if you do, you're now in a different regime.
You've lost something and it becomes
it becomes augmented by these other
because it's not even like we say that somewhat.
We look they don't necessarily look like if I was in a town,
I might look where people are shopping.
But actually what's happened is they're looking at the outputs
of some metrics which tells someone ahead of this
the the
key performance indicators
from which they can algorithmically make some decisions.
And it all starts to, you know, rolled out.
And one of the things that does mean in the initial stages
with, say, food, like one reason for say,
oh, why would I go to McDonald's?
Like, well, at least they think they wash, they don't know it.
But by washing everything in ammonia
or by basically buying things always not having a code I
which is not an incidental thing in some areas.
So you go there and it's like it becomes like this will never fall
below a certain standards.
That's what their main thing is.
We've got buckets and buckets of disinfectant around the back,
so you never have to worry about any of the equipment blah, blah, blah.
But of course, the downside of that is
that you
get into this vicious cycle of mechanization
which, you know, suits that kind of
producer.
That reminds me a lot of our discussions with Steven Fox,
I think in 27 about industrial engineering,
and before Dean could even reload, there was the craft dimension
and it was about the integration of craft and industry
and how just bringing up here's the tolerable limits like that.
Does it mean that you're going to take it
to some extreme over mechanic sized way?
But balancing those two,
I just want to return to a specific scenario, particular scenario
in a city that will help us extend and connect to the paper.
And then we're going to go through some of the terms
and actually just stay with one model
and look at what does an active inference model of a city look like.
Some people may read Savile's paper and then think, OK, it was prose.
I didn't see a figure I didn't see an equation. I didn't see an example.
So what are we going to do to actually connect this to my local public
transit planner or this grant that we have in this area?
Steven.
We could use an example.
Helping to connect people connects across agent culture
and using public spaces and
Internet access.
So using actually the project, we're just looking at the moment
where we're putting in a Y find mesh in a community
as sort of a newcomer community, relatively low income.
So this questions about, OK, do you do you bring in resources
so that people get
more stuff at home?
And then how much of that stuff at home
is enough to leverage something outside of just in in
how does that then leverage doing something with it
back in the community, making it something that extends the leash,
you know, and things like Meetup so I think that's a familiar platform
which has been quite useful for people to self-organize.
So we see this ability to do that through the Internet. But of course,
well, what's the ability to
do that in real life as well, like the coffee
shops, the cafes, you know, so you know, you know, anyways.
Yeah, let's pick a we can do like a meet up,
you know, planned or unplanned meet up at a certain spot.
But let's pick like a very specific scenario
where somebody can say, I haven't seen that be modeled this way.
There are new ways that we can now
talk about that scenario.
So many important areas connecting across ages and cultures, et cetera.
So let's think of some public space like we could do.
Say a cafe, a cafe adjacent to a park.
Let's say that.
And we know that that will might be related to other cafes,
which we say if there's this cafe next to a park.
And how does that relate to
you know, getting a coffee?
But obviously it's not just about getting the coffee, is it?
That is an interest in.
Yeah. What does that relate to the niche?
So we're going to talk about this
so how does that relate to the niche,
the ability to have action policies, the ability to serve service needs?
Yes. But also service wants and loves.
So actually in actually one thing
that you might find an interest in in in the
in the development world when they're trying to look at more complex
context is you got needs want and loves.
What would what needs to happen,
what would I want to happen, what would I love to happen?
And often what would love to happen is actually more generative.
We often everyone wants to talk about needs
or I need to get a cup of coffee.
OK, ego.
I need what she needs now.
I need a drink. OK, here you go. And it's kind of stuck, right? Well,
what do you want?
What would you love?
And that's kind of what humans have a role in.
You know, we're not a machine that needs filling in one humans.
So I wonder how you what your thoughts are in terms of how that
so a café should we think of because we're all going
to have a different cafe in our minds.
Here.
Let's yeah, I agree.
You know, it
shouldn't be like the cafe on in my little town on this corner.
So we're going to talk about a cafe adjacent to the park also.
Dave, thanks for the cool sumo references in the live chat.
I think that's an example of how you can scaffold and use ontology
as a thought pump
and explore formal dance towards the formal
and then back towards the qualitative.
So it's a cafe adjacent to a park.
We're not describing the territory that would be like a Boris
horror novella where we're trying to describe to the atomic level,
you know, the paint coding on the street light.
So dispense we're doing a human centric model.
Maybe there are assistant animals, but we're going to build up the model
and that's why we're discussing this on the slide with dimensionality.
So what's the dimensionality of a cafe next to a park?
I mean, the question barely makes sense.
You could have a parameter in your state space
for every molecule of air, but we're talking about a communicable,
simple model that might be on some sort of perretto optimal front, Bayes
optimal front of accuracy and complexity.
So it's like I can't explain this to the local politician
in a third of a seconds, but 3 minutes is probably too much.
So we're going to find some communicable level of detail and make a use
oriented act in skeleton and then see where that takes us in.
So this is a I'm asking this question because I don't really know
if we've got a cafe adjacent to a park, are we having some kind of a
are we assuming some kind of a compounded sense around
what is an attractor state here?
So it's a great question like dwell times,
like maybe there's some transition frequency from the cafe,
you know, from non locations that we're not even discussing.
It's not the whole world.
This is our map.
It's just a little map into the cafe and then from the park to the cafe
and then there's like the ingress and egress of the park
and then it's relationships.
So we could even start to think about like nodes and edges
that are connecting the location of a person.
Stephen And then we'll start working through the list
or feel free to say in the Yeah.
Think that's the image
I was thinking about like the non equilibrium steady state is.
So maybe we need to think, OK, you've got cafe adjacent support.
OK, so like you say, you could be what's the non equilibrium
steady state of that grass if there's grass on the edge of the park.
Right, OK, what's the non equilibrium steady state for the
the behavior section.
And she has some really interesting work and that's how we have does
with behavior settings so maybe that could be another.
So and of course
we'd have to see what scale.
So again, what sort of scale is friendly to this kind of question.
If, if
the behavior setting was just kind of it's kind of an idea of the niche
almost as is capitulated by each person.
And of course this is where the challenge is in terms of
if I'm going to be taking the sensory state perspective,
I kind of have to take an agent.
Yes. There's no sense to outside of a specifically defined agent.
So which agent are we going to be looking at?
So we take the risk, join us, take the barista. That might be easier.
Look, let's just do human. OK? Human, OK,
so these are people who we're talking about.
There's other entities
there could be drones flying around for sure. There's ants.
There's all kinds of stuff happening in the territory, allegedly.
But we're going to be making a reduced dimensionality model,
maybe one that has low computational overhead or maybe one
that's easy to communicate or one that explains a lot of variance.
But not every single nook and cranny.
So we're going to be talking about humans in the cafe
adjacent to the park in a city Dean.
So if we're looking at this through the lens of active inference,
there's two things now that have been raised.
One is, do we have do we have an attractor state?
And meaning will people migrate, will they move, will they congregate,
will they gather?
And then Stephen brings up the idea of, OK,
so how do people remain in that non equilibrium steady state?
How does the expectation now
get realized once the migration has occurred?
This is what an action in active inference
working together allows where something gets kicked out at the end
right?
Some some material thing with with ingredients
that we can now account for gets kicked out at the end.
But in the meantime,
what we have to do is we have to actually look will people gather?
Is this actually a place that people will now move towards?
And then because that's a city right?
They've all congregated.
And then we have to ask is will expectations meet intentions?
That's what active
that's what going through an active inference process actually affords.
It doesn't guarantee, as you said, Daniel doesn't guarantee this.
The specifics and the particulars
what it does, it holds up on a more abstracted level
for a longer period of time before energies actually applied,
before something actually materialized.
And I think that's what gets most people up
because there isn't a critical path ready to be fulfilled.
It's an act of inference process that has to have certain
anchors in the ground
before you can before an anchor is meaning abstract
that you have to have available
that act as affordances that eventually kick out the blueprint,
which eventually kicks out the dwelling the edifice.
Thanks, Stephen.
And so you've got this kind of broader dynamic.
So again, so resolving scales again.
So it comes in because it's like there's going to be the broad level
customers and someone serving in the cafe right
a Starbucks customer, a barista.
It's a tie in with that vibe.
You've got
they've got a different tell logical expectation even in the abstract.
We haven't even worked out who they are right now.
Of course, that's not quite so true.
If one of the customers is
an adult with three year old child the three year old child's
expectations are slight different in terms of what it is to go in there.
So you've got this, but essentially speaking, there's
a regime of behavior that each of them are totally logically attuned
to to some extent.
Look, let's go through these terms in this order
and there's a specific reason why.
So affordances are capacities for action.
They're what actions are selected from? Yes,
they're ecological et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
Which affordances will we put in our model?
So taking out a phone of your pocket, it's an affordance
but is that the model that we're making?
So again, not the dimensionality of the territory, but what is our model
are we interested in treating the person like a blob?
And the affordance is literal.
Just go to the park or leave the scene
and so we can have a simple matrix.
Are you going to be in a three by three matrix?
Are you going to be in the cafe in the park or neither with a transition
on the off diagonal and the diagonal would be your dwell time.
So that is like the person is just like a point OK.
Also, affordances can be zoomed in and a lot more granular.
The affordances could be the angle of every joints in the person's body
and that might be relevant if the steps are going up to the cafe
and someone doesn't
have joint mobility to raise up their leg, a certain level,
then that is going to influence their transition movement matrix.
So when we course grain to just the blob
and that three by three transition matrix which is simple,
that may abstract above important layers.
So that's why iterated modeling is really important.
But iterating means we need to have something there to iterate on.
So for a first past, do we want to do a model of movements of the people
among the different spaces so that would be like one example.
Another example would be like, we're interested in drinking behavior.
So the affordance that we're going to
model is the choice of no drink, coffee, tea, smoothie.
So we're making a kind of behavioral economic model
and actually we're not as interested in the movement transitions.
We're interested in how the knish,
the temperature influences people's buying habits.
Or we could have both.
We could have where they are as a blob and what drink they buy.
Or we could have where they are and all their joints
and what drink they buy.
And then looking at the phone, that's the dimensionality of the model.
It's not the dimensionality of the territory
because we're still talking about the same place.
So what kind of affordances do we want to focus on?
Like we know that you could do anything
a person could do is going to be in Affordance,
but what affordances are we going to be talking about here?
I like the idea of working with the where, the awareness,
and I think there's a lot of tendency for what person orders,
what the thing is,
the sort of thing that you can in some ways potentially emulate in that
I don't think you can emulate the way in this in a lab like so
what sort of zones might they occupy like this, this around round
tables there's around the doorway.
So it could be, you know, you've got these.
Yeah, you've got the park. So even more broadly,
yeah, it might be a very broad level. There's the cafe there's the park.
And then that can, that can then break down by some zones
or maybe they've pulled out from the model
but so yeah.
So these, this is going to be fun because I'll just do like so
the diagonals of the Matrix this is like a movement matrix.
So the stay is the number could be like zero to one.
The probability in the next hour
or the next minute is not an absolute claim. It's time dependent.
And then you could imagine within staying at the cafe,
we could
make another little matrix
that had the table, the bathroom, the counter,
but it would be only and strictly within that top left cell,
that's the sub matrices that we were looking at in number 32.
So we're going to be in a state
and that's what course screening means somewhere.
Someone can't look at our matrix and say, How could you not have modeled
the counter in the bathroom when people have great,
we made a three by three matrix,
now let's make a sub matrix and let's make that fine grained or
and that sub matrix could be defined in terms of Chronos.
Like what is your coordinates in the cafe three comma, four or it could
be Kairos, they're at the counter or they're doing something spatially.
We're not putting a number on it.
So staying is the on diagonal
because we're making a course grained movement model.
We're not looking at their elbow angle,
we're not looking at where they are inside the park.
This is a first iteration an of a model.
And then if there was surprise coming from our model
discrepancies with the observations,
just like asked if we could update our model.
But again, iteration entails
we need a complete model before there's anything to discuss.
If people are just throwing out random core terms and terms
outside of the active ontology it's part of a discussion,
but we're not iterating on a model, so it's fine.
But that's not making an active inference model. Dean
and then will continue.
So I like this because materialization piece.
No, what gets kicked out is on a gradient descent.
But, but my question again then is so
when you're talking about affordance, are you including availability
as in what Steven was talking about?
Because of where I am now, things are at hand or proximal
or are you talking about threshold lowering, meaning ease
at which something can be attained is they're not
they're not the same thing.
And I want to know whether or not we're including both in terms of
crystallizing this materialization
Stephen.
And then we'll come to that.
And this is helpful. Like nothing is good.
This idea is truly down.
And I suppose this is this is this extra question.
Maybe it's at the side there, but is how much to
does the nature of things change by being in
the conversation or being how much by staying in one location
or moving between locations?
Is that question about this kind of
I suppose is it's kind of fluidity. Right.
And that's an interesting side question, which.
We can we can put it in our model.
We can we'll be able to actually iterate on that question.
And I'd argue this isn't drilling down. This is building up.
There's nothing to drill into until we have this fully described.
Otherwise, it's just like to people aren't
you can't drill into a linear model that hasn't been specified.
So there is no drilling down
until we're talking about something particular.
And then we could coarse grain
or we could fine grain, or we could iterate or elaborate or transpose,
but we're at the zero to one step in active modeling here. Dave.
Yeah, and
making those transactions actually change
as the inventory of potential affordances of other participants.
When you walk into a room, you give every person in that room
seconds to either greet you and establish
a potential relationship or to say, Oh,
this guy doesn't want to talk to me, or he would have nodded
or Goffman goes into painful detail on how that stuff works.
The and that one relationship can persist for years.
The guy you nod to and the guy you never to, you know it up or down.
And it's very personalized and cultural and that's definitely
like a level that we we haven't even gotten into the entire agent.
OK, but we can we'll we'll get there
and we can see is this part of our zero to one model
or is that going to be included in our one to two model
but repeatedly returning to not not you know,
it seems about thing but just repeatedly returning
to aspects of the territory before we have a model to iterate on.
The model is going to remain uncompleted
and you'll have done a partial inventory of a territory
in a totally ad hoc pseudo linear way when it could have been all there
and iterated using our ontology and framework,
which we're here to work on. Dean and then Stephen.
Is the sedan
and maybe you can help me because I say when I think about this,
the availability piece
because it's proximal doesn't mean that it's not on a on a high shelf,
meaning high threshold.
And I can't, I can't get the coffee bag down
that's full of the beans, right?
So again, I like what we're doing here,
but I still ask when we're talking about affordances, how are we
are we are we looking at two ways of describing that at a minimum,
because that's what I'm hoping we're doing.
But if we're not, what are we doing
Stephen, you are going to
you are going to give me some some thoughts around that.
Yeah. First, Stephen, with a recent.
Yeah, that got me thinking.
Allan's been
the question I suppose is as well as well as iterating on,
you know, we can run multiple examples of
so they might be one of these cases.
Like you say, many things can happen, but you could one
you know, you could have two or three types of models
kind of simple and you run them all many times and see OK
and maybe change some parameters to make something
more likely that there's a long term relationship,
that there's a perception, binding energy that kind of is exhibited.
And then you can sort of look for clusters
of transitions, clusters of behavior or
patterns.
Right?
And so then we're sort of comparing patterns and to some level,
then it's in a way it becomes a sense making process for us
and the advantage we've got is
we can tap back into our embodiment because we're humans.
So you say, OK, I see in that,
what sense do I bring a higher dimension to all of that?
Yeah, you can have 500 groups of three separate
and make their own active model of a cafe adjacent to a park
but they all have to get that zero to one.
Otherwise, if they come together, what is there to discuss?
500 times 00. So I wasn't so much thinking of one as much
think about different people.
I'm thinking even though the person does the module,
you just literally run it lots of times, but slightly different tweaks.
And then so you get you can sort of get something from that.
I would say that's a different type of
maybe you start to see some of these patterns.
That's iterated modeling with getting the first version
and then changing parameters and iterating and then looking for patterns
across iterations that are achieved via a certain strategy
of changing parameters but incomplete model will never run. So
yes, there's
a total space to do stochastic simulation
and run one model 5000 times and 5000 different models one time.
And every other combination,
they all are predicated on iterating on something that already is there.
And so that's the zero to one phase. Steve.
I was puzzled how you translate the stories that you find in
so many academic papers or semi academic papers, sociologists.
Great. Is that something like this happens,
this happens is how do you turn that into simple?
Very simple exists, exists person, person enters room and I'm going
and you throw it in the model
and if it says contradiction, something's wrong.
If you're really confident that, hey, that's the way the real world
goes, you negate it, you throw a does not exist
and you got a universe and run it and it blows up.
So I guess not everybody does.
What I said is wrong. Let's find out what I did wrong.
Cool stuff.
You don't even need the exotic.
You don't even need to recreate
mathematically oriented modeling tool.
You can just do it in pure yes or no. True or false logic.
Just realize that this morning and level it up.
Nice.
Yeah.
Take people out their work.
Just used their word and they asserted that this.
And then I hope they used nouns and verbs
and if so, then you could be able to parse it.
So let's we're making a course grained movement model. So again,
it could be fine step.
You could have the affordance
be to take a step and the location to be something else. Fine, great.
But we're taking a course right now.
We're going to talk about the sense of the agents.
So their actions or their movements,
which is just a coarse green movement state.
That's the actions that they're doing. Inference on
what are their perceptions?
We know about the five 1155 senses.
It's not about the scent of coffee in this model.
Again, the future model with which thing they bought you could go to
what is their sense of smell.
But here we're just going to do a sense mapping matrix with light.
OK, so the cafe is going to have red light. I love red light.
So the cafe is going to have basically an 80% chance of red light
if you're in the dark room, a point to chance of sunlight.
If you're at the window seat and it's never dark
if you're in the park, there's a 100% chance of it being sunlight.
There's no
there's no red light in the park.
And there's no darkness in the park. So it's like the daytime.
So again, that's iterating. So it's good to keep those things in mind.
You like have a coda or a space where you could have everyone's
perspective added, even when you're building a first iteration.
But some matrices do need to be specified to continue talking about it
as an active inference model.
And then neither will say neither. It's never read.
There's a rare red light that the cafe uses, and it's half the time
sunny and it's half the time dark
because that's who knows, we just have maximal uncertainty,
but we know that it's not red.
OK, so this is how the a matrix in active inference.
If you said you're in a dark room
where are you?
Well, here, given these simple numbers,
we know that we're in neither the cafe or the park.
If you said you're in a red light, where are you?
You must be in the cafe. The only place with a red light.
If you said you're in the sun,
what is the probability that you're in the park?
It's two thirds roughly. This is 1.7.
And so it's one divided by 1.7 is literally the probability
of being in the park conditioned on seeing sun.
So that is Bayesian statistics.
It's like we have a matrix of sensory mappings
and then it's like, here's a new observation, it's red.
You go, OK, it's 0.8 over point eight that I'm in the cafe.
OK, so that is the sense mapping matrix.
What is the inference on what is the s the hidden state where am I?
That's not directly observed.
You're observing only the photons in this model.
So the, the this is a mapping between
the oh, the observations
and then
the s the states that inference is being done on.
But aren't they thinking about their to do list? Yes.
In the territory keep it in mind. Add a note, add a comment.
We want to hear your perspective.
That's not the course Green Movement model.
So these are active teams for simplifying teams.
OK, we have the perception, which is the sense here.
Three states and we have the locations that inference is being done on.
Now we can talk about preferences, what our preferences for
this is like perceptual
control theory, perception preferences are over observations
so it's like the preference is to observe the body being in homeostasis.
That's part of the preference specification in active
so one could imagine that if somebody had no preference
for any of the I don't really care
then they would move proportionally
to the ratio of the transitions of the Affordance matrix.
So if all the transition frequencies were even and there was no
preference over sensory outcomes, you would be evenly distributed.
If there is a preference for darkness,
no matter how slight and there's any ability to move into the neither,
then that will be the attractor because individuals will dwell
in a more preferred state because they prefer the darkness
which is only accessed here if there's a preference strong,
then exaggerated, like a strong preference for sun,
we would see like everyone or almost everyone in the park,
a weak preference for sun would only slightly bias towards the park.
D Yeah, I think there
I'm asking should we assume that the preference
is to be vertically caffeinated or a caffeinated inverted
and not being a smart apple? I'm asking that.
Is that the assumption that we're building our model around?
Because you asked.
Here's here's the interesting thing about this model.
As we're building it in the first iteration, the sense is visual.
So there's no coffee in this model?
No, I know you do, but why isn't there? Right.
So if we could we could talk about
a different affordance matrix, a different sense mapping.
It could be Intrasection, it could be my
excited or not.
And then
do I prefer to be excited or relaxed?
So just two introspective states.
Then there's an affordance which is to drink coffee or not,
which is to have some probability
of moving you from one state to another.
OK, coffee is increasing your likelihood
of getting excited versus not doesn't.
That is not a spatial model
so now we could make that preference overcaffeinated states
and that's like a module that's going to compose very
interoperable with a spatial model
because the affordance vector, the sense vectors,
those can be heterogeneous that can be here's the three by three spatial
and the two by two caffeine.
And those are sub matrices.
And it does turn out that the cafes where that affordance is enabled
and there isn't the affordance for the coffee in your in the park.
But those are two types of
observations. There's the photon observation
which we're using as a proxy for location.
And then there would be the interception
which is related to the cafe nation state
and then those could be combined
and you could have a joint density, overcaffeinated and location.
And then policies like where to move could be selected based upon
the long term expected free energy
given the preferences and affordances of that agents.
So there are different modules
that can be composed in an integrative modeling
framework for perception, action and cognition hashtag active inference.
Dean And then Stephen. Yeah. Just real quickly,
I was going to say I was going to answer my own question.
I think then in terms of a preference confirmation, the iconography
on the side of the Cup would seem to fit with within the niche as well.
So maybe it's, maybe it's a large acacia tree in green.
So I wasn't seeing it in the sense that we were
I don't want to drag this off course when I actually reinforce
the idea of how preferences align as opposed to saying,
why aren't we including that?
I'm kind of reinforcing the sense mapping matrix. Thanks, Stephen.
Hello.
Yeah, I'm
yeah, I think this is I suppose one thing I'd like to check in
with though, as we just doing this, take a little bit of practice
you got, you kind of got with Deonte X, you kind of got exotic, huge,
kind of got the I can make a choice between the affordances for action.
So it's sort of coming slightly from a more deductive kind of scripts
triggering world, which is useful.
I'm also wondering there could be
say, for instance, that that sense mapping matrix
as well as it being something
that, you know, links
someone's preferences back to where they go more broadly.
So that's quite useful.
But I'm wondering also
if someone's navigating a space
and there's there's maybe within the camp,
there's some red, there's some some this is dark.
You know, I know you talked about embedding there's
there's there's a question about
but is there a tendency to to move towards the on tick type of
structuring because it kind of takes us there.
And if there was to be a kind of a more
gradient based
transition that's happening in relation to space,
it might be different.
You know, how much does this adapt to that
or does it need to be rethought in terms of the type of marketing?
OK, so this is, of course, green model.
So to see that it's 80.8 read in the cafe and point two in Sun
in the cafe corresponds to 20% of the locations have sunlight on them.
So one could then make a sub model where at table one it's 100% sunny.
So you're still in a sub matrix
that core screens to 8020 but there's two tables that are in the sun
and then there's eight that are in the RET,
so then you would have affordance matrix
within the cafe sub matrix of moving over ten by ten tables.
But one can see that as you include more rows in the matrix
you get exponential explosion and that
proposes computational challenges
and just like parameter identification challenges
because maybe you never saw someone go from seven to two,
but it's not that it can't happen, it just there's only
80 people who went to the shop and there's 100 transitions,
so it just you're not going to see all them.
So then you get a very poor estimate of 100 parameters that's why
we're talking about modeling, not what is happening in the Territory.
This is going to give you some course grain results.
Then the sense mapping matrix is preference free.
It is not a preference matrix. The preference matrix C
is where the preferences are specified over sensory outcomes only.
So here's Dean who has like a nine to three of right over son.
Now Dave has one point, one to one.
So they both prefer red over son.
But we can see in the model stream
one, Ryan Smith and Christopher White, we talked about like what
these numbers mean, the ratio, their absolute amount, et cetera.
So we're not going to talk about it here.
But Dean has a stronger preference for red over son,
whereas Dave has a weak preference
for red over some OK, so we have the preferences over the observations.
OK, we have the affordances, coarse grained movement,
not the elbow motion, not which table coarse grain moving.
We know that we could make a sub matrix.
Then there's the action states, which is moving from one to another.
Then there's perceptions,
the observations, the sense states, those are photons, not location,
but there's a matrix now that could be a fixed matrix
or it could be learned, but we're just starting with a fixed matrix.
We have preferences over observations
those are only over colors of light.
And so for Dean, it's just a vector of three, but we're just contrasting
two different agents that are in this cafe area.
Then we have expectations.
So expectations are the generative model.
What would be expected
observations.
And so Dean says, I'm
the kind of person who expects and prefers read a lot
that will shape which of these affordances are taken.
And so Dave and Dean can have the same sense mapping matrix.
They don't differ in how they infer where they are given the photons.
But the affordances can also be the same
and they'll have different behavior.
So that's how you get agent specific behavior from a model like this.
You can have agents with the same preference,
but they differ in affordances or some other combination
that's iterating and enriching a model.
And then just one thing here before we go to the question, Steven,
so what is the niche?
So yes, again, the territory with the everything is
just everything in the world, but the niche is the generative process.
So the agent is the generative model
and the niche is the generative process that's actually like handing
those observations to the agent in this case, it's
just the emission of photons.
It's literally just the light source is the niche
because we're making a super simple model where the only observation
that's getting handed from the niche is photon.
So the only
thing we need to say for the niche is it's the process
the hidden process that emits photons.
Maybe it's a red light bulb, maybe it's red
cellophane and it's white light, or that's the hidden generative process
the niche in this case is just the process
that emits observations to the agent
so that they can then integrate that into their generative model.
Stephen, did you want to. Yeah.
Yeah, I think, I mean, rather than necessarily emission of photons, you
could say it's like the perception of light is it could be perception.
The agent perceives the observation of light,
but the niche is the process that gives rise to agents observations.
Ryan OK, if you take it from the red, it red is not photons.
That's the perception of study.
Without getting into what is red.
Do we also see that we're talking about the mapping between
the perception of what is called in English red and the location state.
And the location state now? Exactly.
And so you then go, well, two questions.
One questions, you know, the next you've got 930 as opposed to doesn't.
So how do you scale that line?
Would you you don't do it.
So they always number one is the highest
and you've actually gone above one there.
So is that they use a different
how would you scale what the maximum is? Yeah.
So this is what we talked about in module stream
one with Brian Smith. But basically
these numbers do get normalized to
some to one to be a proper probability in a soft max function.
Oh, I think you just sums them all up
and then to by sums them all up and that's.
How you get the probability proper from this.
But then the ability to have it go beyond just one.
So that's the difference between like you know, five and one versus 50
and ten,
depending on the generative model,
those might behave very, very differently.
Going yeah.
Just first of all, this is fantastic to build it in real time,
but I want to just now ask a question.
So, so and then in real terms, you built this model
and it kind of makes us aware of things that we
maybe wouldn't be aware of
because we work in the active inference realm.
But now my question is, so so now
is this is this also projection
or what kind of inferences do we make of this in terms of agents
go, don't go, because that's weapon to me.
Then that's when the real value
is realized
because we can't predict with certainty who goes and who doesn't,
who ends up at the cafe with the coffee
and who stays at home and watches friends.
Right? So how so we've got this. This is fantastic.
But now we want to get to a place
where a person who normally would be somewhat risk averse
takes this and goes, Oh my goodness, this opened up something
that I would normally never have a goal, but now I'm prepared to go.
Does it help? Do you think this work helps that person
just off the top of your head?
Because I know it helps me, helps you,
but that person who is trying to do this on that
decision branch moment,
how does it make how does making them aware of this
alter their thinking.
I think it does a few things, some of which we've seen in the past
few minutes, others which probably remain to be explored
it separates out observations from the state that's being inferred
because it'd be very easy just to simply say, well, I prefer the cafe
oh, I'm observing Red in the cafe and I prefer Red.
So by having the preferences over outcomes and then separating the
observed outcome from the inferred, hidden state, you know, if you like,
you like spicy food, that's why you say you like this kind of food.
So pull it back to these matrices.
Let's just say that they knew all the options.
Maybe people are not aware of all the affordances
that they can even take, or maybe they have something to add themselves.
So this is like saying this is like, these are all your chess moves.
We're not. We're playing chess.
So we're not even going to worry about,
you know, knocking the pieces off the table.
Like we're playing a well-mannered chess game.
But we can modify the rules.
But you know, we're playing with the affordances.
So somebody might have their
mind expanded
by just considering all the affordances that are available.
Like, well, I guess I could go to the art museum in the city,
but I'm not that kind of person.
It just hadn't even seemed to me.
So by bringing that regime of attention to affordances,
we're seeing the whole space, then
people can separate out the outcomes that they have preferences over for
the hidden states.
And then affordances are the actions that modify
the transition probability of the hidden states actions.
That's like where the pie plugs into the B,
which is intermediate between the extra time
the pie policy doesn't plug in to changing the state.
You don't have an affordance for red like
you have an affordance
to move to a location that you've inferred has higher red light.
So there's probably many other approaches,
but this sort of like gets the whole map out there
in terms of the space of the possible,
which is again, we're saying that is the space of the possible.
It's not like there's some other secret affordance.
And then you can have a conversation
about how people map
their perceptions, which can include internal perceptions
like being bored or being sad or happy.
That's the whole mental action they can map their
preferences over observations
to inference on states and the affordances that get them there.
Well.
OK, I'm sorry you
you froze for a minute there partway through your explanation.
So if I'm saying something back that you already answered, I apologize.
But so this kind of to me now in
so now that we are talking about regime of attention,
because you are still I still heard
that part that kind of goes back to one of those last screens
before where we were I think I mentioned.
Is it about time on task?
Because we can now measure that because that's
now something that we've easy to measure
or is it still about what have we made available to ourselves?
And so what we get a sense of in terms of what we might be missing,
in terms of change blindness as one example, versus what we now
again, what are what
how we've expanded our awareness
as opposed to what we've given more attention over to.
Because again, my sense is it's it's easy to measure
what I'm paying attention to.
It's more difficult, but probably more valuable to know what
what the possibilities are in terms of that 80, 20
that I may not have been conscious of before.
Does that, does that make sense to you?
Because that's that's how I see this eventually.
Moving on to gradient descent.
Yes. So these are a single level agents right now.
Like they don't have metacognition,
so they're not like, I'm unsure about something
or I'm sad about something, but I'm seeing two cases
where regime of attention applies
it doesn't apply in this current model.
Two regimes of attention.
One would be like an intra model regime of attention,
like we could have in this agent
a metacognitive attentional layer that is either paying attention or not
to sensory outcomes.
And if they're not paying attention to it, it's going to slip by.
And it's like the gradient is flat.
And then the more attention they pay, the sharper
they're going to realize their preferences is like,
wow, it is really sunny out here and I prefer red light.
So I'm going to go because I was brought my attention to it
then there's sort of this like XO model where you're talking about
bringing people's attention to different parts of the model
now that itself could be an active recursive model,
but that's like using this model to draw, to both expand
people's to the space of the possible
and then direct their regime of attention to certain phenomena
or attributes of this model.
So there's I think there's a link
to little bit separate uses, but they both apply.
It do you think do you think the second one
because if I go or I don't go, both of them
give me a feedback loop that I learn from right
so do you think the second one is
nuanced, different than the first or
quite radically different from the first?
Because I know if I don't go
that's quite, quite different, that's the zero.
And if I do go, that's the one there.
They're they're quite separable and quite discrete.
What is what you're describing more of that blur I wasn't in
on the third one I think was where there was no line drawn in the sand
and so I'm wondering
and now I'm wondering about that because again, ultimately,
if we could take this off the page and use it and actually use it
in ways that give us more prediction matter, expertize
boom,
so what do you think?
Yeah, let me type something, Stephen.
Anything, two other
I do. You do.
And I'll say what I was going to say. So ads for
this is slightly different point.
So I want to just let you finish this point and then.
OK, so the first case of the regime of attention is going to be we do a
recursive layer in this agent's so that they can be paying attention to
something or not. OK? Yep.
Yeah, time, energy, a lot done. Yeah.
So the second the sort of application
or communication of the model would be deploying this,
I don't even know.
It's like a meta slash exo model.
Like bring deploy. Are you,
are you coming up with new ways of describing things?
Not during a livestream.
We don't do that. We do that before and then we rehearse remember?
So you could use this model to bring the policy planners
attention to something.
So again, you distinguished
there was first just stating the space of the possible.
So that's not an active secret like the the policy planner, right?
Oh, I guess I never really thought
people would move from the park to the cafe.
Oh, I was thinking how people would get to the park
and then how they'd get to the cafe,
but I didn't realize that they would move between them.
Maybe that literally happens.
So that's just like a movement matrix.
Any kind of systems thinking or design thinking or agent
based model would converge on that, any kind of iterated modeling.
OK, but we're talking about what
active could direct their regime of attention towards.
So let's just say that we had a nice polished dashboard for this cafe
movement simulation, and then we had two kinds of
people.
Somebody with visual scenario A and visual scenario B.
So maybe it could be anything.
It could be their their preferences over ramps, children love ramps.
Some people cannot move up them.
Some people love Bright, some people loved art.
OK, so you can say there are we're going to just say
there's two kinds of agents
in this simulation and we'd like to bring your attention.
Policy planner right.
Your preference over observations, which is like local businesses
being intact, people hanging out in the park during these times a day.
You have these preferences over observations.
We're kind of meeting
you and we're seeing those your observations are our outputs.
Our model is outputting the things that you are observing and caring
and preferring over we've done a suite of model explorations
and it seems a little counterintuitive,
but adding a red streetlight in the park
changes how people use it to it.
Nope, nobody would have suggested the Red Street light
but we know that there's people who love red light,
and it turns out that just having one red street light,
it makes it great for them.
That has totally changed the flow.
Steady state, non equilibrium, steady state
reflecting in a tractor in our model.
Yeah, that has changed and we can see these suite of simulations
that and we're just going to call your attention to this graph
and call your attention to how the points go higher on the y axis
as the x axis dial changes.
But it turns out we don't want only red light in the park.
So we ran a simulation from zero to one, right and sun
half and half and every combination.
And so there's some curve and we'll draw your attention to the point
where that curve is.
That's a great first step and we'll iterate because it's an open source
model and we're in conversation with you and then we'll be able to test
so the map and then the allocation of numbers on the map
is kind of like the regime of attention.
That's our affordances as modelers
and then there's that layer of communicating it clearly
with strings of natural and computer language and visuals
so that the regime of attention of something not in your model
at the core level, like the policy planner, they're like,
Oh yeah, I guess I do expect and prefer this,
and here's somebody who's giving me that expectation and preference
and a toolkit for counterfactuals and elaboration.
And their outcomes are my incomes OK.
Thank you.
No, but that's I think that's helpful because at the end of the day,
there there's somebody who's actually observing this
and putting it into, into each one of these cells.
But I'm not sure that that the people that are actually doing it
are necessarily aware of it.
And so my question is, once they become aware of it,
what can they do with what's the value to that?
Yeah.
So it's like the first ring of the model, you know,
the person is moving.
We could do mean field approximation, really simple.
We could do the trajectory based particle simulation
OK, then what's outside of our model
and the sort of boutique step is communicating to the policy planner.
But now let's just say that I, the modeler, include the policy planner
in this model or they have a different model.
Now, the outcome of the that model is being passed to me.
So you never get around the notion
that there's like a boutique level of communication of the model.
But the idea is that like critical infrastructure could be inside
the model and the boutique communication could be to the public.
And then we would have functional infrastructure and good communication
instead of
little sub ad hoc modules for critical infrastructure
with boutique communication among them.
So that any tenuous wrapper drawn around all the critical infrastructure
is going to be incoherent,
then that incoherent blanket cannot be communicated out.
Another level. Yep.
I think you reinforcing the idea of the difference
between structuralism and interaction
and what you're describing there is kind of the way finder rule
there are coinciding with the person who's wayfinding
stuff. Cool
maybe we'll have templates, guidebooks, playbooks, workshop,
all those things, like what is the right order?
They're probably not only one order, but again,
if we don't have a model to discuss, it's
going to be like getting to point one and then to zero.
And then there's the grass and the grass is alive
and in the grasses, viruses and are viruses alive and what is green?
It's like kind of these like false starts
but I think once
it connects, even conceptually, we didn't write this in code, it's
not even pseudocode, but once it conceptually connects
and then we can say, OK, let's make Affordance Matrix E one
and then let's make E two.
So just like it's an alternate hypothesis on the Affordance matrix,
then we have, you know, a
one and a two, just two hypotheses on the mapping between
hidden states and observations.
And then we're going to run a two by two model simulation.
E one, A1, E1 A2, e to a one, e two A2.
Now we're doing decision supports
and it's up to us because that's the on models is our decisions,
our preferences over the outcomes that we're seeing.
Oh, I like the E2 A1
because I prefer people to be in the park.
And then the cafe owner says, I looked at that one and I liked that one.
Oh, we're modeling ourselves, making this decision, and you like people
to be in the park, and I like people to be in the cafe.
We have a different preference, so we're not going to eliminate tension,
but that's actually a conversation to have versus I consulted this group
and they made this PDF and you did this and they did it a word file.
It's a different file type. They wrote in a different language.
They're not informationally integrated.
What is the comparison? Cool.
You know, a consultant.
But then this is a way where it's
people may call it transparent.
I'm not sure how transparent massive statistical models
will ever truly be, but maybe it's kind of like a transparent engine.
It doesn't mean it's made of glass.
It means like there's a window into it.
So here we can see the pieces going in. There's no side door.
There's no other matrix.
If we specify the partially observable Markov decision process, the MVP,
those are the pieces that went in
and the connectors are also established.
Then we used a message passing algorithm
or some other approach to find parameters.
So which part of that would you like us to interact on?
I mean, that's an actual conversation.
And then even if somebody doesn't know about one part,
they could still be included in that dialog.
Perhaps. Stephen Yeah.
And that that again, you touched on it,
you kind of circle back to a couple times
and you actually used the word support
whether it's support or serve or contribute.
That's kind of the one constant, regardless of what
how it, how it sketches out.
That's the one thing that seems to run through this as a constant what,
how active inference actually supports
what, what inevitably gets kicked over.
But we observe at the end of the day.
Right, like we're doing this, we're using limited high energy electrons
and our attention
and our finite life and everything like that, all these resources
so that we can have decision support in this example.
And then we undertake a policy that modifies the niche, modifies
the generative process, but that's on mild.
Again, we are at the first level
where we don't even have the construction site.
So then we have the model where I can choose to change a light bulb
from the you know, maybe we can add a natural light into the cafe
that would be the next.
That would be like an active model of agents using an active model.
And then that model would still have this boutique layer
that has to be communicated
informally.
And that's like kind of the connective tissue
where you have something that's like a MDP interfacing with the world.
It has to have some sort of an interface like that.
Steven then.
You know, I think this is really helpful.
The affordances thinking of affordances is effectively
the setting up for the action policy
and the generative Genesis model
so you say, OK, in this case this affordances to better stay or move.
And what I think is really helpful,
I'm excited about is and this sort of comes down to those two like
so the dynamic availability or the, the
this could be happening at different rates.
You can have the same model that's here nested at different speeds.
Let's not use the tempo rates of recursion, i.e.
this is a general idea.
There's someone coming,
they go to the cafe and they chose to go to a part of the cafe.
This might be happening over ten, 20 seconds
and they make a choice of where they are.
There might be something about people
leaving the cafe and certain areas over the period of 10 minutes,
but there's also like I'm walking towards a cafe
and I can be making choices.
I can be making
an intuition about what affordances to stay or move.
I go in the cafes or go to the park and I can be thinking about,
I can turn, I can change my position.
I could, I could be flipping off shopping next year
maybe once every half a second over a period of maybe 10 seconds.
And then once I walk through the door, I'm in the queue
I'm pretty much like
in I'm going to be staying for a while, right?
So now I'm in the right now.
So my the rate at which the same idea of the affordances being used
could be now happiness is slightly different nested speeds, right?
Because, OK, that's if I'll maybe choose
I mean here now I'm going to say for a minute or I know I sit down
and then it's like I'm getting into a good conversation,
am I going to stay for 10 minutes?
And they're different, but they're the same in some ways.
So they're different Chronos.
But there's a cross that links the timeliness together
and that's why categorical
cybernetics and event oriented cognition like Martin Boots is recent
guess stream.
The event is I'm ordering there's a beginning and an end to that.
Now, within that matrix or within that event context,
it could be playing out at a second by second.
But then in a different event context, it can be a different model.
And the higher level is which context am I in? What is the event?
So that I think will go a very long way
towards going from like that kind of
auto ethnographic narrative of like I was, I was dangling
and I was moving my elbows sort of in that event context.
You do have the model like I was getting a taxi maybe that has
a different spatial temporal scale, different set of affordances.
And then for our model not for the real world, which isn't changing,
but then in our model we say, OK, once you're in the taxi,
the event is in taxi and we're only going to look at block by block,
or then we slow the model down in the simulation or something like that
when the event context changes
and then we're doing inference at the higher level
on which of that context we're in.
So we would have a way to talk about that
and iterate and include all the richness in the sub matrices
and pull back to the core screen when we have to do that.
Dean.
This is fantastic because it's really helping me.
I hope it's helping me.
Everybody else is watching and participating.
So again,
what I'm hearing is a very clear line being drawn between something.
What we might describe as goal, direct behavior
and the relationship that we're trying to proscribe in three tables.
And it's the relationship between those three tables
as opposed to a specific outcome
which we in our minds say we want to achieve or realized
or recapitulate versus building out a relationship through support,
through serving through contribution.
But that is
that is not a goal that stays on the relational level, never to collapse
underneath that out of that plots out these goals
that can be directed behaviorally.
But then if I'm
if I'm
misinterpreting this, where am I laying something over this
that reconfirms my biases push back on this?
But I think what we continue to do
is reinforce the difference between what we're doing here.
In terms of a model and what effects that can potentiate versus a model
that has a specific and an idealized and a particular outcome.
Am I am I overstepping or overreaching?
No. Thanks for sharing how you see it.
I think the only piece I caught on is goal isn't an active ontology.
We have preferences and expectations, and then we adjust.
We trim tab so that we realize those observations.
And so it's like,
I want to be under the finish line at the four minute and 52nd mile.
That's the observation I want.
Not my goal is to run a 450 mile.
So then there's actually policy selection, how you get there.
And this is from a paper that I'll release very, very soon.
Here's just a re visualization of the MVP that we've seen many times.
It's a little bit adapted from the Mental Action Sandford Smith Paper
and a few other sources, but basically we have this discrete time play
and then we have see the preferences
e the affordances, the possible policies that can be taken and G,
which is the expected free energy calculation.
That's the minimization component.
Those play into Pi PI influences B
which is the state transition mapping of underlying hidden states.
In our model,
that was where one is inferred to be, but not what they're observing.
B is only changing how states transfer to each other.
A which we had is the sense
mapping matrix is mapping from the observations which were photons
emitted by the generative process, the niche.
A is intermediating between the photon
and the inference on where you are.
Sometimes it's really obvious
if it's dark, you're not in a cafe or the park.
If it's red, you're more likely to be in the cafe.
You used to be totally likely,
but now you're pretty sure because we added that red light to the park.
And then there's uncertainty estimates
which can be fixed or learned on all of this.
And this is not the only model architecture
this is a model architecture that we're using to integrate
perception, cognition and action and impact service contribution
Stephen.
Yeah, thanks.
Then it's really helpful and talking about these three to relating.
So as the model is at the moment, you know, the top Affordance matrix
which gives the policy options,
you know, it's giving us sort of the states the possible choices.
So it's fairly set. Okay.
But those the sense mapping in the preference preference matrix
and you could put that temperature into that or you could put variation
of how much So for instance, at certain scales,
you know, generally speaking,
the movement was red when I went to the cafe.
But when you're in the cafe and the lights, maybe the sun goes behind,
the cloud comes out again, you know, maybe in different,
there's different rates at which that can be fluctuating a little bit.
Maybe my preferences as I'm starting
to think about what I like in cafes in general, and then I'm say, well,
you know what I actually quite like in this one, right?
So but what this does with even within this model
is, you know, you could
start to not only change the values,
but you could change how much the values either
just by temperature or noise fluctuation
or maybe there's a tempo of oscillation.
You know, maybe you say that this one goes has the ability to change
within these premises over a five second period,
over a five minute period, or what's happening below perception.
You know, there's a because with circadian, so you could say, okay,
maybe someone doesn't notice there's a dark part of the room
because it's just one table in the corner, right?
So there's something nice about even within this model,
you've got the ability to start to get this nested hierarchy.
Yeah.
Like if you have uncertainty and you allow the parameters
to be learnable in your model, not debating whether people
actually are learning, just we're going to test two models, one
where they cannot learn the mapping,
one where they can learn the mapping,
or we're going to test one where it's just visual versus a sense
it might smell like coffee more outside in the park than in the café
because that's where they vent.
So that could be learned and understood.
And somebody at the first part oh, of course
it's going to smell more like coffee in the cafe. It might not.
So it doesn't have to be the direction people expect.
It can be included in the prior D
That was the only letter they didn't mention was
that's how you get to the first state in the Markov
chain is with the prior and so you can have high uncertainty over prior.
Just say like I don't know where I am and I'm very uncertain or
I'm certain I don't know where I am or any other number of combinations.
And then
the Bayesian information criterion,
just to add like one more little technical note.
So the by sea, it's really just the AIC
but the by sea, it's basically it's a value.
Bic is going to be something related to the number of parameters.
That's the key term that's the number of parameters times
the natural log of a number of data points.
So that's like are you fitting 50 parameters on one data point?
I mean, you can imagine that those are going to be very poor
estimates versus like one parameter on 50.
So then that one parameter that's not the world, right? It's a model.
We're talking about statistical modeling -2 times
the natural log of the likelihood function.
So this is like model complexity minus model accuracy.
So then we can say, OK, I'm testing three different Affordance Matrixes.
One is the three by three, one is a nine by nine
because I've split each of the zones
into three parts and there's like the window was very sunny
and then 5050 and then a very red part.
And then I have another one where it's 500 by 500
and like the first ten columns are the same
because like they're all sunny and then the second one are all the same
and they're very similar to the first ten.
One can
imagine that depending on what kind of data they have
and how much data they have,
they might find that the by sea
for the three by three, nine by nine or 9000 by 9000 model is supported.
And so that wouldn't be saying
the territory is three by three, nine or 900.
It wouldn't even be saying that the map is three by 39 by nine, 9000.
It'd be like saying this is a Perito optimal Bayes
optimal statistical model
that's on a frontier manifolds between explaining variance
while reducing model complexity.
So it's like that's the level above the map
and that's where the by sea and model selection comes into play.
You don't just do the bottom up
and then finish your model at the zero to one.
That's the iterating.
We could have a whole network or matrix of models and then have
principled ways of selecting among them and adding a new data.
Designing Counterfactuals.
What would be the most informative data point to obtain or what would be
a perturbation that would distinguish these two different hypotheses?
Those are the kind of maximum information foraging questions
because they amount to which policy as a modeler
will reduce my uncertainty about dot, dot, dot
that might be formalized in this matter Excel model,
or it might not be,
but we can use like active quant as our kernel
and then active qual as our wrapper hashtag dot coms.
Dave and then Steven.
Have activities of navigating among models at various scales
and topologies that you, as you've been describing,
have those been observed adequately to tell to
what degree free energy is being minimized during that evolution?
That's a great question.
Potentially for Marten Boots or for someone else,
which is kind of the first principles, unifying theory angle,
which we didn't even mention today in Active would be like this
would we have a common currency
or could we understand actions selected in different contexts
as being in the same game of reducing expected free energy?
So then could we look at
like we have the sub matrices within Cafe Park and neither
and then like we're looking at the fine scale transitions
as in a free energy minimizing process and the macro transition.
And then looking at how like
small and large changes in expected free energy are related to sort of
micro and macro transitions in a hierarchical model is all you're asking
yeah.
Whether using this modeling framework
exhibits the kind of behavior that allows you to evaluate
the free energy principle and its friends
plot in the real world.
And for one thing, are people just plain turning on data collection
adequately?
Dunnicliff did that weigh decades ago when he was developing latex,
he turned on this massive data collection
everybody in his organization was feeding in exactly to the key
press is being captured.
And then he ran matrix metrics on that and says, well,
this is where we're putting our attention.
I'm trying to make things easier
and I'm making them harder. Well, that's wrong. Let's start working.
And if you hadn't collect the data, you know, he would
he wouldn't have been able to give
all those speeches about how how it worked
and how you study the ecology of software development.
This stuff is a lot cooler than anything that he ever did.
I think that we're moving from a zero to one
to a continuous deployment of models landscape, which puts us squarely
within the scope of active because we're no longer doing
descriptive analysis, like how was this car made?
We're doing like continuous deployment on the ship, a thesis,
and that is going to give a lot more information
and then whatever information is collected will respect that as being
observations.
So whether we have every keypress and every mouse movement
and the pupil diameter and the eye gaze and the natural language
processing on the live stream and, and, and all of those things,
it's still would just be observations
and let them debate whether it's all them ones that we need,
but then we'll specify our matrices we'll use.
I see iterate with the real world. And
yeah, I think that between the git commits
and the language use and the absolute accuracy or validity of the model,
there would be quite some interesting patterns to see like does
as the accuracy versus git commits.
Do you like go really fast up and then dip and then recover accuracy.
Do you have a prolonged period of low accuracy followed by like a phase?
Transition was like, oh, once we added in the sense of smell,
it just was like, wow, then it fit or is it like some other dynamic?
Or how does that relate to the language use?
How does it relate to the saliva cortisol metabolite?
Like there's no end to what you could bring into the model
because they're just observations.
And then the relationships among different kinds of observations
is something that's learned
and we'll use the besi and related techniques
like Bayesian model reduction and structure learning,
which first and pointed to as the key open problem
in the DART tools section of our June 21 symposium structure.
Learning is how you go from just proposing variants on matrices
and exploding your model space
to actually finding models that are on that frontier of being useful
so very interesting question, Dave.
Thank you, Stephen.
That way I want to give closing closing round of thoughts there now.
So I will just say that
that was really helpful to have this diagram here.
So just because you got
so you got preferences and affordances for action straddling,
you can see my hands straddling the strategy which is coming
from all the sensory kind of interpretation, so to speak.
And one question I've got is
you know, you got uncertainties there and I know this
just purely more from an instrumental kind of practical point is
as it influences at the moment, that's kind of like I suppose
you could have a big matrix and the uncertainties could be flips.
They flip on and off what's available.
It's like you can move, you can't maybe you have to stay,
maybe at some point you've got no choice. You've got to stay right
whereas in the other ones the numbers.
So it could be you could vary them so you would try and change.
You would you would treat those matrices slightly differently
because the other one, you need the switch and on and off
options for what you could do.
And down, low down, you could do something to change that number
between either zero and one or whatever.
So just wondering what your thoughts are on that. Yes.
So this is just one architecture and one representations.
I'd be totally open to being wrong in these points,
but I'll just bring up what I think is interesting about that.
Notice that the uncertainty is on a not oh, so you could say
my thermometer says 22.2, but I don't know how that maps
to the real temperature because it's a noisy thermometer.
That's zero ambiguity about the thermometer.
So if but if you say, I'm not even sure what the thermometer says,
it's 20 something,
then you need another model with what is the visual observation
mapping to the thermometer reading, mapping to the temperature.
So uncertainty in that.
Just one interesting point is it's not connected to Oh I see.
But of course we have uncertainty about what we're seeing.
It's a blur, right?
But if you don't even know if you saw it or not,
you're even another level removed.
So you could be uncertain about the mapping from whatever
the thermometer says to temperature.
The extreme case being you're so uncertain about the mapping of a that
even when you visually see it says 22, you're just like,
I literally got no information on the real temp or if a take mapping.
But that's one thing that doesn't have an uncertainty associated with it
and he had not that it couldn't is just that maybe it doesn't need to
and then the other one is as you pointed out
there's no uncertainty over PI
that I find quite interesting
and I think the reason why is we're not doing inference on PI
we're conditioning all of our analysis,
conditioning our free energy calculation
horizontally. In on PI.
So we're saying there's three options
and I'm conditioning the expected free energy of one, two
or three conditioned on selecting one, two or three.
So it is a little bit of a different variable.
And also action is not in this.
It's implicitly in there because the B matrix,
which we can have uncertainty on in how the B matrix,
how policy's map to be and how B maps to states.
So a technical phrasing would have to clarify like,
you know what, I drew the red line here to the middle of the edge.
Is that an uncertainty on the mapping of PI to be or is that a
mapping on so it's not a technical claim, it's a visual artifact.
But I think it might be possible to have no uncertainty on observation
and no uncertainty on policy
and that could just compress the computational complexity
by a huge amount
and all the other ambiguity
could actually be like very nicely dealt with elsewhere.
But if it's like
I'm just thinking of other examples, people can probably imagine
if there's uncertainty on what policy you're conditioning on.
I think the analysis starts to lose sense
like conditioned on left to right.
Am I going to get the food that makes sense, conditioned on I'm
not sure if I'm going left or right
I don't see how there could be anything other than
you don't know
it's not a conditional,
so you can't get a marginal likelihood from a Bayesian perspective.
So yeah. Stephen Yeah.
Last last, last point, I suppose it's that question saying just do it
type of thing, isn't it?
With a policy is like you've got the option of just doing it right?
So you say, OK, I'm just going to, I'm going to do it and run with it.
So I don't have the benefit of actually then going
and starting to tweak it all the time.
But you've got that all round.
The point is this put it all around it in the conditionality
I think you just said and then run it. And then
I suppose it is it is what it is and it's about some of these
the best you've got.
So, you know, if you're an organism, basically
the policy you've got is the policy you've got, though
you know, you can
you can go back and change your preferences because of what you did.
And ultimately that's all you got, you know,
so maybe you just have to sort of run with it.
And you'll either resist dissipation or not.
Dean and then Dave, if you'd like a closing thought.
Yeah. Mike So here's my closing thought
so today we basically pulled out a material relationship on that slide.
We built it in real time
and we were making a comparison to the material city of a city state.
I think to bring it back to the paper.
Back to the paper note, I think this is really important
because I actually support a lot of what what the what Surveil wrote.
And I also believe that what we were talking about
was material generative models
out of that, there's a kind of a parallel
to an iterative process.
All right.
So even in even in the diagram that you have up here,
this is kind of confirming iteration.
So whether that iteration is in iterating, filling in
a table versus it being blank, right.
There's an iteration process or the city grew from 12 buildings
to to 1200 that's an iterative process or, or whatever.
We've got multiple multiple confirmations of the fact that at scale
iteration is it is a thing, it's a material thing.
What I'm going to go away from today's conversation
because I don't know the answer to this, but no, I got to think about
this is so when we when we move away from those things that fall out,
those those capitulations that fall out in terms of skyscrapers and
nine by nines from three by threes,
do we trust the map where the blueprint where do we trust the process
meaning critical path in the same material way?
Because I think in the in the point one
as you said, Daniel, we're just talking about zero to one right now,
but at some point we're going to have to get past one.
And yet the real bootstrapping going
and then the question is, do we have to now incorporate
something to get outside of scale free for that to make sense?
And that's going to be my question to myself
is do we materialize the trust in these models
the same way as we materialize the model themselves?
That's going to be my I'm going to go think about that for a few hours
because that would burn a few neurons for sure.
It'll go up in smoke.
But thank you for this
because this was really helpful to me. Incredibly helpful.
Thanks.
You know, when I was in module stream one with Ryan and Christopher,
and they were going through it.
And so
there are better people and will be better people
to teach it and walk through it and they'll be a million ways to do it.
So it's a funny thing that it happened in 33.2.
A funny thing happened on the way to 33.3.
But yeah.
Dave, any last comments?
Yeah, the question of uncertainty over
policy required means a lot of reflection and study.
And I would suggest one thing to look at is what exactly is repression
like that's all I have to say for now.
Yeah.
OK, fellows, thank you very much.
Congrats to those who have listened to the end
and you're always welcome to participate in Active Lab.
So thanks again and peace out. Thanks to you. By.